witaj ponownie w kursie „Rozumienie kwantowej informacji i obliczeń", nazywam się John Watrous i jestem dyrektorem technicznym ds. edukacji w IBM
Quantum. To jest 12. lekcja serii i ostatnia lekcja w trzeciej jednostce, która dotyczy ogólnego
sformułowania informacji kwantowej. Ta lekcja skupia się wokół fundamentalnego pojęcia w informacji kwantowej, mianowicie puryfikacji stanu kwantowego.
Puryfikacja stanu kwantowego reprezentowanego przez pewną macierz gęstości to
czysty stan większego układu złożonego, który pozostawia nam oryginalny stan, gdy reszta układu złożonego jest
odrzucona lub wyśladowana. Każda macierz gęstości ma puryfikację i możemy dowiedzieć się wiele
o stanach kwantowych i informacji kwantowej ogólnie, badając puryfikacje. Na poziomie intuicyjnym
wektory stanów kwantowych reprezentujące stany czyste są prostszymi obiektami matematycznymi niż macierze gęstości, i myśląc o
puryfikacjach stanów, możemy patrzeć na dowolne stany kwantowe układów jako na będące jedynie częściami czegoś większego, ale
prostszego. Omówimy też wierność między dwoma stanami kwantowymi, która jest wartością kwantyfikującą ich
podobieństwo lub nakładanie, i jest często używana jako sposób mierzenia, jak dobry jest dany stan w porównaniu z
pewnym idealnym stanem. W szczególności omówimy definicję wierności wraz z kilkoma jej podstawowymi właściwościami i zobaczymy,
jak wierność łączy się z puryfikacjami. Oto przegląd lekcji — zaczniemy od puryfikacji, w tym
definicji i prostego dowodu ich istnienia, który mówi nam, jak znaleźć jedną, gdy jej potrzebujemy. Następnie omówimy coś zwanego
rozkładem Schmidta wektora stanu kwantowego dwóch układów i zobaczymy, jak rozkłady Schmidta odnoszą się do
puryfikacji. Następnie omówimy krytycznie ważną relację między dowolnymi dwoma puryfikacjami tego samego stanu, zwaną unitarną
równoważnością puryfikacji, a na koniec przejdziemy przez kilka przykładów. Następnie przejdziemy do wierności,
w tym jej definicji i niektórych jej podstawowych właściwości. Omówimy lemat łagodnego pomiaru, który jest bardzo
przydatnym faktem wiążącym wierność z powrotem z pomiarami, a na koniec, kończąc lekcję, przejdziemy do twierdzenia Uhlmanna, które
ustanawia fundamentalne powiązanie między wiernością a puryfikacjami. Zacznijmy od
definicji puryfikacji. Puryfikacja stanu, który zakładamy jest reprezentowany przez macierz
gęstości, to czysty stan większego układu złożonego, który pozostawia oryginalny stan, od którego zaczęliśmy, gdy reszta
układu złożonego jest wyśladowana. Możemy wyrazić to bardziej precyzyjnie w terminach matematycznych w następujący
sposób: jeśli mamy układ X w pewnym stanie rho, co oznacza, że rho jest macierzą gęstości reprezentującą stan X,
a s jest wektorem stanu kwantowego pary układów XY takim, że wyśladowanie Y z czystego stanu ket psi bra psi
pozostawia nam rho, to mówimy, że s jest puryfikacją rho. Naturalnie nazwy nie mają znaczenia —
możemy nazywać nasze układy i stany jak chcemy, i kolejność układów też nie ma znaczenia, na przykład
jeśli układ Y byłby po lewej, a nie po prawej, ale wszystko inne byłoby takie samo, to nadal odnosilibyśmy się do psi jako puryfikacji rho. Będziemy się jednak
głównie trzymać tego ustawienia przez resztę lekcji dla uproszczenia. Pierwszą rzeczą do powiedzenia
o definicji jest to, że puryfikacje zawsze istnieją dla każdej macierzy gęstości rho. Żeby być bardziej precyzyjnym, każda
macierz gęstości rho ma puryfikację jak opisuje definicja, pod warunkiem że układ Y jest co najmniej tak duży jak X,
co oznacza, że Y ma co najmniej tyle klasycznych stanów, co X. Pojęcie puryfikacji i
fakt, że puryfikacje zawsze istnieją, okazuje się być krytycznie ważny, i jest też częścią tego, co sprawia, że informacja kwantowa jest piękna, i mam nadzieję, że
uda mi się cię o tym przekonać do końca lekcji. Udowodnijmy teraz, że każda macierz gęstości ma puryfikację, i
w trakcie procesu zobaczymy, jak możemy zdobyć puryfikację, gdy jej potrzebujemy. Podobnie jak w definicji
puryfikacji, załóżmy, że X jest układem, a rho jest macierzą gęstości reprezentującą stan
X. Teraz rozważmy dowolne wyrażenie rho jako kombinacji wypukłej stanów czystych, jak mamy zapisane na ekranie. Słowami,
dla pewnego wyboru dodatniej liczby całkowitej n mamy wektor prawdopodobieństwa P 0 przez PN minus jeden, a także wektory
stanów kwantowych fi 0 przez fi n minus jeden, i uśredniając odpowiednie stany czyste ważone przez prawdopodobieństwa,
otrzymujemy rho. Na przykład moglibyśmy użyć twierdzenia spektralnego, żeby uzyskać wyrażenie rho w ten sposób, i jeślibyśmy to zrobili,
moglibyśmy wziąć n jako liczbę klasycznych stanów X. W istocie moglibyśmy wziąć n jako rząd rho, który jest
równy liczbie niezerowych wartości własnych rho, licząc każdą tyle razy, ile wynosi jej krotność, i
to nigdy nie jest większe niż liczba klasycznych stanów X, ale może być mniejsze. Z drugiej strony, nie musi to
być rozkład spektralny rho i nie potrzebujemy, żeby te wektory stanów kwantowych były ortogonalne — na przykład dowolne wyrażenie rho w ten sposób
jest w porządku. I oto puryfikacja rho. Suma przebiega po tych samych wartościach, co
w naszym wyrażeniu rho, i wewnątrz sumy bierzemy pierwiastki kwadratowe prawdopodobieństw pomnożone przez fi a tensorowane
z ket a. Zakładamy nawiasem mówiąc, że 0 przez n minus jeden to klasyczne stany drugiego układu Y, więc
ma sens, że s jest wektorem stanu kwantowego pary XY jak w definicji. Tak naprawdę nie jest ważne
w tym miejscu, że używamy stanów bazy standardowej Y w tym wyrażeniu — możesz podstawić dowolną ortonormalną kolekcję
stanów w miejsce ket 0 przez ket n minus jeden, jeśli chcesz. Możemy teraz sprawdzić, że to jest rzeczywiście
puryfikacja, obliczając częściowy ślad po Y. Oto wyrażenie stanu, które otrzymujemy, wykonując częściowy ślad.
Ślad ket a bra b wynosi jeden lub zero w zależności od tego, czy a jest równe b, i tak wyrażenie
upraszcza się do naszego oryginalnego wyrażenia rho, i to takie proste. Bardzo łatwo więc zdobyć puryfikację,
o ile mamy wystarczająco dużo klasycznych stanów Y, albo alternatywnie wystarczająco duży ortonormalny zbiór do użycia
w miejsce stanów bazy standardowej ket 0 przez ket n minus jeden. Nawiasem mówiąc, jeśli liczba
klasycznych stanów Y jest mniejsza niż rząd rho, to nie będzie puryfikacji, i zostawiam to tobie
do przemyślenia, jeśli chcesz. Oto przykład. Rozważmy
macierz gęstości, którą widzieliśmy kilka razy w lekcji o macierzach gęstości. Mamy tu wyrażenie tej
macierzy gęstości jako kombinacji wypukłej stanów czystych — nie jest to rozkład spektralny, ale nie
ma to znaczenia. Bez większego wysiłku możemy zapisać puryfikację stanu, stosując
przepis. To nie jest jedyna puryfikacja tej macierzy gęstości — puryfikacje nie są unikalne, ale to jest w porządku. Definicja
definicja nic nie mówi o jednoznaczności, a w rzeczywistości istnieje bardzo interesująca zależność między różnymi puryfikacjami tego samego stanu, ale
omówimy to trochę później w lekcji. Następnie rozważymy dekompozycje Schmidta, czyli wyrażenia
bipartytowych wektorów stanu kwantowego w pewnej formie, którą zaraz opiszę. Są one nazwane na cześć Erharda
Schmidta, tego samego Schmidta, który jest znany z procedury ortogonalizacji Grama-Schmidta, ale w przypadku dekompozycji Schmidta prawdopodobnie nie powinny
być nazywane jego imieniem – jest to w rzeczy samej matematycznie równoważne czemuś zwanemu rozkładem według wartości szczególnych dla macierzy, co było
odkrywane wielokrotnie, ale tak to bywa. W każdym razie, oto co rozumiemy
przez dekompozycję Schmidta: dla dowolnego wyboru wektora stanu kwantowego s dla pary
układów X, Y zawsze możliwe jest zapisanie s w specjalnej formie, która jest taka, jaką
mamy tutaj na ekranie, gdzie R jest pewną dodatnią liczbą całkowitą, p₀ do p_ są dodatnimi liczbami rzeczywistymi tworzącymi razem
wektor probabilistyczny, x₀ do x_ są wektorami jednostkowymi odpowiadającymi układowi X, a y₀
do y_ są wektorami jednostkowymi odpowiadającymi układowi Y. Może to nie wyglądać szczególnie
specjalnie, dopóki nie powiem, że oba zbiory – x₀ do x_ i y₀ do y_ – muszą być
ortonormalne. Dlaczego to jest specjalne? Cóż, gdybyśmy wybrali dowolną bazę dla jednego z dwóch układów, powiedzmy
wektory X odpowiadające układowi X, to zawsze moglibyśmy wyrazić s w tej formie i to wymusiłoby wybór
wektorów Y w określony sposób. W rzeczywistości robimy to dość rutynowo, jak przy standardowej bazie, gdy
przygotowujemy się do analizy pomiaru w standardowej bazie. Ale ogólnie, nawet jeśli wybierzemy ortonormalną bazę dla wektorów X,
wektory Y, które uzyskamy, niekoniecznie będą ortonormalne. Podobnie, gdybyś wybrał
ortonormalną bazę dla wektorów Y i próbował wyrazić s w tej formie, możesz, ale wektory X niekoniecznie byłyby
ortonormalne. I wreszcie, gdybyś wybrał ortonormalne wektory dla obu układów i
próbował wyrazić s w takiej formie, niekoniecznie by się to udało, bo możesz potrzebować pewnych wyrazów krzyżowych, a tu jest tylko jeden
indeks w tej sumie, więc forma jest specjalna. Ale zawsze możliwe jest
zapisanie danego wektora jednostkowego s w ten sposób, i oto jak możesz to zrobić: najpierw oblicz rozkład spektralny
zredukowanego stanu dowolnego z dwóch układów – nie ma znaczenia, którego. Ale żeby opisać, jak to zrobić, przyjrzyjmy się zredukowanemu stanowi
X, czyli śledzimy po Y. Oznacza to, że p₀ do p_ to wartości
własne tego zredukowanego stanu ρ, a x₀ do x_ to jednostkowe wektory własne odpowiadające tym wartościom własnym. Przy czym
rozumie się, że pomijamy wyrazy, dla których wartości własne wynoszą zero, bo te wyrazy nic nie wnoszą do
sumy. Czyli p₀ do p_ to wszystkie dodatnie liczby rzeczywiste, a R to liczba niezerowych
wartości własnych z ich krotnościami, co jest równe rzędowi ρ. To daje nam p₀ do p_
oraz x₀ do x_, i pozostaje znaleźć wektory y₀ do y_.
Istnieje tylko jeden wybór, który może zadziałać – te wektory są w tym miejscu jednoznacznie określone i można je
łatwo znaleźć za pomocą prostej formuły pokazanej na ekranie. I co zadziwiające,
jeśli zdefiniujemy te wektory w ten sposób, to gwarantujemy, że będą ortonormalne, co daje nam dekompozycję Schmidta. Nie będę tego uzasadniać w tym
filmie, ale nie jest to zbyt trudne i możesz zajrzeć do pisemnych materiałów do lekcji, jeśli chcesz. Sprawdź
opis filmiku po link, jak zwykle. Na przykład rozważmy ten
wektor stanu kwantowego, który otrzymaliśmy jako puryfikację przykładu macierzy gęstości, do którego wciąż wracamy.
Nie jest to dekompozycja Schmidta, bo stany zero i plus nie są ortonormalne, ale możemy znaleźć jedną
używając procedury, którą właśnie opisałem. Pierwszym krokiem jest obliczenie rozkładu spektralnego dla zredukowanego
stanu X, który jest tym samym przykładem macierzy gęstości. I oto rozkład spektralny, który widzieliśmy
w lekcji 9. Wybieramy więc p₀, P₁, x₀ i x₁, jak pokazano
na ekranie. p₀ i P₁ to wartości własne ρ, a x₀ i x₁ to
odpowiadające im jednostkowe wektory własne. Pozostaje więc obliczyć y₀ i y₁, i jeśli to zrobimy, dostaniemy ket-plus
dla y₀ i -1 × ket-minus dla y₁. To nie jest oczywiste – musisz
faktycznie wykonać obliczenia, żeby to zobaczyć, ale właśnie to uzyskujemy. I zgodnie z oczekiwaniami te dwa wektory są ortonormalne,
co zawsze będzie miało miejsce, jeśli obliczyłeś to poprawnie. I to daje nam dekompozycję
Schmidta. Dekompozycje Schmidta są bardzo przydatne w wielu sytuacjach i wkrótce zobaczymy, co mówią nam
o puryfikacjach. Puryfikacje nie są jednoznaczne – dany stan kwantowy reprezentowany
przez macierz gęstości będzie miał w rzeczywistości nieskończenie wiele puryfikacji. Istnieje jednak ścisła
zależność, która zawsze zachodzi między dowolnymi dwiema puryfikacjami tego samego stanu, i jest ona czasem nazywana unitarną
równoważnością puryfikacji. Oto jak to działa: niech ρ będzie macierzą gęstości
reprezentującą stan kwantowy układu X, i załóżmy, że mamy dwie puryfikacje tego stanu, będące
stanami czystymi tego samego złożonego układu. Dla konkretności załóżmy, że s i φ
są wektorami stanu kwantowego pary układów X, Y, i oba dają ρ po wyśledzeniu układu Y.
Unitarna równoważność puryfikacji mówi, że musi istnieć operacja unitarna U działająca tylko na
układzie Y, która przekształca s w φ. Innymi słowy, choć są to
dowolne puryfikacje ρ i nie zakładamy o nich nic poza tym, że obie puryfikują ρ i są
stanami tego samego złożonego układu XY, muszą być w pewnym sensie równoważne, z dokładnością do operacji unitarnej na Y
samym. Zobaczymy kilka przykładów, które ilustrują, dlaczego to jest interesujące i jakie ma implikacje. Najpierw jednak zobaczmy,
dlaczego to jest prawda. Zacznijmy od rozkładu spektralnego ρ, który jest
macierzą gęstości puryfikowaną przez oba s i φ, i tak jak przy omawianej dekompozycji Schmidta,
przyjmiemy, że pominęliśmy wszystkie wyrazy odpowiadające zerowym wartościom własnym. Zatem p₀ do p_
to wszystkie dodatnie liczby rzeczywiste, x₀ do x_ to ortonormalne wektory własne ρ, a R to
rząd ρ. Przy okazji, jako dygresja, zauważ, jak często sięgamy po twierdzenie spektralne w tym momencie –
to niesamowicie przydatne narzędzie, bez którego bylibyśmy zagubieni. W każdym razie, mając rozkład spektralny
ρ, możemy obliczać dekompozycje Schmidta naszych dwóch wektorów, tak jak wcześniej, i będą one
niemal dokładnie takie same. Współczynniki i wektory X są takie same, bo pochodzą z rozkładu spektralnego zredukowanego stanu, który
jest taki sam dla obu wektorów. Jedyna różnica polega na tym, że możemy uzyskać różne wektory dla drugiego układu. Dla
pierwszego wektora, którym jest s, dostaniemy jeden zbiór wektorów y₀ do y_, a dla drugiego wektora, którym jest φ, dostaniemy
być może inną kolekcję, którą możemy nazwać z₀ do z_. Mamy więc teraz dekompozycje Schmidta
dla naszych dwóch wektorów, które wyglądają bardzo podobnie, z wyjątkiem tego, że wektory dla drugiego układu mogą być różne. Ale są to
dekompozycje Schmidta, więc obie te kolekcje są ortonormalne, i możemy po prostu wybrać
unitarną macierz U, która wysyła yₐ na zₐ dla każdego a. Zawsze możemy to zrobić – operacje
unitarne są w rzeczywistości równoważne odwzorowaniom liniowym przekształcającym jedną ortonormalną bazę w drugą. Jeśli
te dwa zbiory przypadkowo nie obejmują całej przestrzeni odpowiadającej Y, zawsze możemy je oba rozszerzyć do ortonormalnych
baz, używając, jakże stosownie, procedury ortogonalizacji Grama-Schmidta. I tak właśnie jest dowodzimy unitarnej
równoważności puryfikacji. W lekcji czwartej serii omawialiśmy protokół supergęstego kodowania,
który pozwala nadawcy przesłać dwa klasyczne bity do odbiorcy, wysyłając jeden qubit, za cenę jednego ebita
wspólnego splątania. Zakładam więc, że znasz już ten protokół, a celem tego przykładu jest krótkie
wyjaśnienie, jak łączy się z unitarną równoważnością puryfikacji. Pamiętaj, że protokół działa tak:
Alice i Bob współdzielą ebit, czyli innymi słowy stan Bella φ⁺. Alice wybiera, żeby przekształcić ten
stan Bella w dowolny z czterech stanów Bella, w zależności od dwóch bitów, które chce wysłać, a następnie wysyła swój
qubit do Boba, który mierzy, by sprawdzić, który stan Bella ma. Zauważ, że wszystkie cztery stany Bella
dają ten sam zredukowany stan dla qubitu Boba, którym jest stan całkowicie mieszany, i to już wystarczy
do stwierdzenia, że supergęste kodowanie jest możliwe. Wszystkie cztery stany Bella puryfikują stan całkowicie mieszany, więc z unitarnej
równoważności puryfikacji wiemy, że musi być możliwe dla Alice przekształcenie stanu Bella φ⁺ w dowolny
z pozostałych poprzez zastosowanie jakiejś operacji unitarnej do jej qubitu. Oczywiście nie trudno wymyślić operacji unitarnych, które
faktycznie działają, i są one bardzo proste, ale mimo to interesujące, że możemy dojść do wniosku, że jest to
możliwe, nie myśląc nawet o samych operacjach unitarnych. Co więcej, możemy stwierdzić,
że uogólnienia supergęstego kodowania na większe układy są możliwe, pod warunkiem że mamy jakiś sposób uogólnienia stanów Bella na większe
układy tak, by wszystkie dawały stan całkowicie mieszany jako zredukowany stan Boba. I istnieją różne znane sposoby, by to
zrobić. Innym kontekstem, do którego unitarna równoważność puryfikacji ma implikacje, jest kryptografia
kwantowa. Jedną z najważniejszych jej implikacji jest to, że wyklucza istnienie bezwarunkowo bezpiecznego kwantowego protokołu dla
prymitywu kryptograficznego zwanego zatwierdzaniem bitu. Co to jest zatwierdzanie bitu? Zatwierdzanie bitu to przykład
prymitywu kryptograficznego, przez który rozumiemy zadanie lub procedurę niskopoziomową, która zapewnia pewną podstawową funkcjonalność, mogącą
następnie służyć jako budulec do robienia bardziej interesujących rzeczy, takich jak tworzenie schematów podpisów cyfrowych lub budowanie
protokołów zerowej wiedzy. W przypadku zatwierdzania bitu podstawowa funkcjonalność polega na tym, że jeden
gracz – Alice – może zatwierdzić wybraną przez siebie wartość binarną drugiemu graczowi – Bobowi, ale jej wybór pozostaje ukryty,
dopóki nie zdecyduje się go ujawnić. Wymagamy od protokołu implementującego zatwierdzanie bitu dwóch konkretnych własności:
musi być wiążący, co oznacza, że Alice nie może zmienić zdania po zatwierdzeniu bitu, i
musi być ukrywający, co oznacza, że Bob nie może ustalić bitu Alice, dopóki nie zdecyduje się go ujawnić.
Byłoby więc całkiem nieźle móc implementować ten prymityw przy użyciu informacji kwantowej, bo jest to
użyteczny prymityw, ale okazuje się, że bez żadnych dodatkowych założeń jest niemożliwe zrobić to doskonale z informacją kwantową, ani nawet bliskim
doskonałości. Unitarna równoważność puryfikacji ujawnia to na bardzo ogólnym poziomie. Chodzi o to, że gdyby istniał kwantowy protokół zatwierdzania bitu, musiałaby istnieć tak zwana puryfikowana wersja tego protokołu, gdzie możemy wyobrazić sobie, że
Alice ma układ A, Bob ma układ B, i po zatwierdzeniu, ale przed ujawnieniem przez Alice, para AB jest w
jednym z dwóch czystych stanów ψ₀ lub ψ₁, w zależności od bitu, który Alice
zatwierdza. Jeśli protokół jest doskonale ukrywający, to Bob nie może odróżnić
dwóch zatwierdzeń, więc jego zredukowany stan musi być taki sam dla obu możliwości. To jednak implikuje, przez
unitarną równoważność puryfikacji, że Alice może przekształcić jeden w drugi, stosując jakąś operację unitarną
na A samym. Protokół całkowicie przestaje więc być wiążący. Są tam szczegóły, które pominąłem,
ale sedno sprawy jest takie, że unitarna równoważność puryfikacji mówi nam, że tego prymitywu nie możemy niezawodnie implementować przy użyciu informacji kwantowej bez dodatkowych założeń jakiegoś
rodzaju. Ostatnim przykładem implikacji unitarnej równoważności puryfikacji jest twierdzenie znane jako
twierdzenie Hughstona-Jozsy-Wootterse'a, w skrócie twierdzenie HJW. Zacznijmy od sformułowania
tego twierdzenia – to nieco uproszczona wersja, żeby uniknąć pewnych zawiłości technicznych i skupić się na głównych
ideach. Załóżmy, że X i Y są układami, a F jest dowolnym wektorem stanu kwantowego reprezentującym czysty stan pary
XY. Załóżmy teraz, że myślimy o zredukowanym stanie układu X samego i wymyślamy dowolny sposób wyrażenia tego zredukowanego stanu
jako kombinacji wypukłej stanów czystych, jak pokazano na ekranie.
Na przykład liczba N w tym wyrażeniu – czyli liczba stanów czystych, po których uśredniamy – mogłaby być
dowolnie duża, być może znacznie większa niż wymiar przestrzeni odpowiadającej X lub Y. Twierdzenie mówi nam, że musi istnieć pomiar układu Y z N wynikami, taki że
zachodzi co następuje: po zmierzeniu układu Y, po pierwsze każdy wynik pomiaru
pojawia się z prawdopodobieństwem dokładnie równym odpowiedniemu prawdopodobieństwu w naszym wyrażeniu zredukowanego stanu X jako
kombinacji wypukłej stanów czystych, a po drugie, po uwarunkowaniu na uzyskaniu konkretnego wyniku pomiaru stan
układu X staje się odpowiadającym mu stanem czystym z kombinacji wypukłej. Dlaczego to jest
interesujące? Cóż, oznacza to, że dla dowolnego sposobu, w jaki zdecydujemy się myśleć o zredukowanym stanie X jako kombinacji wypukłej
stanów czystych, istnieje jakiś pomiar Y, który efektywnie sprawia, że ten sposób myślenia o zredukowanym stanie X staje się
rzeczywistością. I co niezwykłe, jest to możliwe nawet wtedy, gdy stan F jest wybrany najpierw, a kombinacja wypukła
jest wybrana później. Tak długo, jak to jest wyrażenie zredukowanego stanu X, zawsze znajdzie się
pomiar Y, który działa dokładnie w ten sposób. Zobaczmy więc, jak to możemy udowodnić.
Zaczynamy od dwóch różnych wyrażeń dla zredukowanego stanu X, który nazwiemy ρ dla wygody.
Następnie wprowadzamy nowy układ Z, którego stany klasyczne są możliwymi wynikami pomiaru, czyli
indeksami w naszej kombinacji wypukłej. I teraz możemy zauważyć, że dwa następujące wektory stanu kwantowego –
γ₀ i Γ₁, oba będące wektorami stanu złożonego układu XYZ –
są puryfikacjami ρ. Żeby było jasne, gdy myślimy o tych wektorach jako puryfikacjach ρ, traktujemy
układy Y i Z razem jako jeden złożony układ, który jest wyśledzany, pozostawiając
ρ. Pierwszy wektor γ₀ jest zasadniczo tym samym co oryginalny czysty stan φ, z tą różnicą, że inicjalizujemy
nowy układ Z do stanu zerowego. Wyraźnie widać, że jeśli wyśledzimy Y i Z, zostaniemy z ρ. Zatem γ₀
jest puryfikacją ρ. Drugi wektor Γ₁ jest zasadniczo wektorem, który otrzymujemy przez puryfikację
ρ na podstawie kombinacji wypukłej, tak jak opisałem wcześniej w lekcji. Tym razem układ Y jest
inicjalizowany – zakładam dla uproszczenia, że zero jest stanem klasycznym Y, ale możesz podstawić dowolny
stan standardowej bazy, a nawet dowolny czysty stan Y, i nie zrobiłoby żadnej różnicy. W każdym razie, wyśledzenie Y i
Z znów pozostawia ρ. Podsumowanie jest więc takie: obie są puryfikacjami ρ, a zatem przez
unitarną równoważność puryfikacji istnieje operacja unitarna U na parze YZ, która przekształca γ₀ w
Γ₁. I to wszystko, czego potrzebujemy, żeby podać opis pomiaru, który robi to, co mówi twierdzenie.
Prostym sposobem jego opisu jest diagram circuit'u pokazany tutaj na ekranie. Słowami: zaczynamy z
stanem φ, wprowadzamy Z zainicjalizowany do stanu zerowego, wykonujemy U, a następnie mierzymy górny układ, czyli Z, pomiarem
w standardowej bazie. W efekcie przekształca to φ w Γ₁, i
patrząc na opis Γ₁, widzimy, że robi to, co mówi twierdzenie: uzyskujemy
każdy wynik a z prawdopodobieństwem pₐ, i po uwarunkowaniu na uzyskaniu a, układ X pozostaje w stanie sₐ.
Żeby było jasne, sam pomiar, którego istnienie implikuje twierdzenie, jest zaimplementowany przez
wszystko wewnątrz przerywkowego prostokąta na rysunku. Jeśli chcesz wiedzieć, jak
pomiar można opisać jako kolekcję macierzy, oto ich wyrażenie. Nie będę tego wyjaśniać i nie jest to
naprawdę ważne dla tego przykładu, ale to jest wyrażenie macierzy pomiarowych na wypadek, gdybyś był
zainteresowany. Następnie omówimy wierność, która jest miarą tego, jak podobne są dwa stany kwantowe, lub alternatywnie jak
bardzo się pokrywają. Zacznijmy od definicji, która może wyglądać nieco tajemniczo na
pierwszy rzut oka, ale ją rozplączemy i mam nadzieję, że pod koniec dyskusji przekonam cię, że jest to
w rzeczywistości znacznie ładniejsza funkcja, niż mogłoby się początkowo wydawać. Oto
definicja: wierność między dwiema macierzami gęstości ρ i σ jest równa śladowi pierwiastka kwadratowego z
pierwiastka kwadratowego z ρ pomnożonego przez σ, pomnożonego przez pierwiastek kwadratowy z ρ. Omówmy to –
najpierw spróbujmy po prostu zrozumieć samą definicję. Mamy trzy pierwiastki kwadratowe i
wszystkie odwołują się do pierwiastka kwadratowego z macierzy dodatnio półokreślonej, którym jest, jak omawialiśmy w poprzedniej lekcji,
jedyna macierz dodatnio półokreślona, której kwadrat daje tę macierz, z której bierzemy pierwiastek. Ponieważ
ρ jest macierzą gęstości, musi być dodatnio półokreślona, więc możemy z niej wyciągnąć pierwiastek, a jeśli pomyślimy o pierwiastku kwadratowym z ρ ×
σ × pierwiastka z ρ przez chwilę, widzimy, że to też jest dodatnio półokreślone, i w szczególności możemy to zapisać jako
M† × M, gdzie M to pierwiastek kwadratowy z σ pomnożony przez pierwiastek kwadratowy z ρ, więc możemy wyciągnąć
pierwiastek. Możemy w szczególności obliczyć rozkład spektralny z pierwiastka z ρ × σ × pierwiastka z ρ, a następnie żeby wyciągnąć pierwiastek, wystarczy wyciągnąć pierwiastki z wartości
własnych i zostawić wektory własne bez zmian. I wreszcie bierzemy ślad
tej macierzy, a ponieważ ślad jest równy sumie wartości własnych, otrzymujemy wyrażenie, które mamy tutaj
po prawej. To jest coś, czego prawdopodobnie nie chcesz obliczać ręcznie w ogólnym przypadku i to wyjaśnienie może nie oferować
zbyt wiele wglądu w wierność ani w to, dlaczego nam na niej zależy, ale mam nadzieję, że wyjaśnia techniczne
znaczenie wzoru. Przy okazji, jako dygresja, czasem ludzie definiują wierność jako
kwadrat funkcji, którą tu zdefiniowałem, i nazywają tę funkcję wierością pierwiastkową.
Zobaczysz oba sposoby definicji, co na pewno może powodować zamieszanie, ale zazwyczaj nie powoduje,
bo ludzie zazwyczaj są dość staranni w precyzowaniu, której definicji używają, i powinieneś
robić to samo. Moim zdaniem nie ma tu jednej właściwej ani złej definicji. Ja definiuję ją
w ten sposób po prostu dlatego, że przyzwyczaiłem się to robić tak, i myślę, że jest to nieco wygodniejsze, bo wolę podnosić
do kwadratu niż wyciągać pierwiastek później, gdy zaistnieje taka potrzeba. Ale oczywiście jesteś wolny dokonać własnego
wyboru. W każdym razie wróćmy do wierności tak jak ją tu zdefiniowałem. Istnieją inne równoważne sposoby
definiowania wierności i jest to naprawdę zadziwiająca funkcja pod tym względem, którą można scharakteryzować na dość interesujące
sposoby. Oto dość prosty sposób przepisania definicji w kategoriach normy śladowej, którą widzieliśmy
pod koniec poprzedniej lekcji. Nie wchodziłem zbytnio w szczegóły normy śladowej i w szczególności nie
definiowałem jej dla macierzy niehermitowskich, ale ma ona wystarczająco prostą definicję. Jednym ze sposobów definicji normy śladowej
dowolnej macierzy M jest to, że jest ona śladem pierwiastka z M × M† lub równoważnie śladem pierwiastka
z M† × M. Uzyska się tę samą wartość w obu przypadkach, i możemy użyć tej definicji do uproszczenia
definicji wierności, jak mamy na dole ekranu. To jest miłe, bo ujawnia, że
jest symetryczna względem obu argumentów. Możemy też wyrazić normę śladową kwadratowej macierzy M jako
maksimum wartości bezwzględnej śladu M × U po wszystkich unitarnych macierzach U. To nie jest oczywiste, ale jest
prawdą, i daje nam kolejne wyrażenie na wierność. Mamy więc tutaj trzy
równoważne definicje wierności, i to dopiero początek – istnieje kilka innych równoważnych definicji, i
zobaczymy jedną szczególnie ważną, pochodzącą z twierdzenia Uhlmanna, pod koniec lekcji.
No dobrze, to wszystko pięknie, ale co to wszystko znaczy intuicyjnie i dlaczego powinniśmy się tą
funkcją przejmować? Żeby odpowiedzieć na te pytania, pomocne jest rozważenie szczególnego przypadku, w którym przynajmniej jedna z dwóch macierzy gęstości
reprezentuje stan czysty. Jeśli oba stany są czyste, to
wierność jest po prostu wartością bezwzględną iloczynu wewnętrznego dwóch wektorów stanu kwantowego, i pod pewnymi względami
jest to główna motywacja samej wierności. Wartość bezwzględna iloczynu wewnętrznego dwóch wektorów stanu kwantowego
jest zawsze liczbą między zerem a jedynką i daje nam naturalny sposób mierzenia, jak bardzo pokrywają się dwa
wektory stanu kwantowego. Możesz myśleć o wierności jako o użytecznym i dobrze zachowującym się sposobie rozszerzenia
tego sposobu mierzenia pokrycia ze stanów czystych na macierze gęstości. Jeśli jeden ze stanów jest czysty,
a drugi niekoniecznie, to znów mamy proste wyrażenie na wierność, które może być całkiem
przydatne, i wyrażenie to jest pokazane tutaj. Wierność ma wiele interesujących
własności, co jest jednym z powodów, dla których jest używana. Ma definicję, która nie jest zbyt
ładna, ale jest bardzo użyteczną funkcją mimo wszystko, i jest często bardzo łatwa w użyciu, częściowo ze względu na wiele jej
zadziwiających własności. Przyjrzyjmy się więc niektórym z nich, zaczynając od obserwacji, że wierność między dwiema macierzami gęstości
jest zawsze liczbą między 0 a 1. Wynosi zero wtedy i tylko wtedy, gdy stany
są ortogonalne, czyli obrazy są ortogonalnymi podprzestrzeniami lub równoważnie iloczyn dwóch macierzy jest
zerowy. Wierność wynosi jeden wtedy i tylko wtedy, gdy dwie macierze gęstości są równe. Każdy inny przypadek jest gdzieś pomiędzy,
ale intuicyjnie, im wierność jest bliżej jedynki, tym stany są bardziej podobne, lub alternatywnie
im bardziej się pokrywają. Wierność jest też symetryczna – wspomniałem o tym przed chwilą. Jest to
dość oczywiste z wyrażenia, które widzieliśmy dla wierności w kategoriach normy śladowej, ale jest to ważna rzecz do rozpoznania
mimo wszystko. Następnie, wierność jest multiplikatywna dla stanów produktowych, co oznacza, że wierność między dwoma
stanami produktowymi jest zawsze równa iloczynowi wierności między poszczególnymi
stanami. Oto bardzo użyteczna własność: jeśli mamy dwie macierze gęstości tego samego rozmiaru
oraz dowolny kanał przyjmujący te macierze gęstości jako wejście, to wierność może tylko wzrosnąć, gdy kanał jest
zastosowany do obu stanów. Innymi słowy, w sensie wierności kanały mogą jedynie uczynić stany
bardziej podobnymi do siebie – nie mogą uczynić ich mniej podobnymi. I na koniec, dla tej listy przynajmniej,
istnieje dość bliska zależność między wiernością a odległością śladową między stanami, która jest zdefiniowana
jako połowa normy śladowej różnicy dwóch macierzy gęstości. Odległość śladowa między dwoma
stanami silnie łączy się z tym, jak dobrze możemy je odróżnić, o czym mówiliśmy w poprzedniej lekcji w kontekście
rozróżniania stanów i twierdzenia Holevo. Natomiast wierność kwantyfikuje, jak bardzo dwa stany
się pokrywają. Chociaż nie są one dokładnie tym samym, nie dziwi, że istnieje zależność między tymi
dwoma wielkościami. W każdym razie te nierówności, zwane zwykle nierównościami Fukuldy-van der Graafa,
precyzują matematycznie tę zależność. I jest dość ważne, że nie ma tu żadnej zależności od rozmiaru rozpatrywanego układu.
Możemy zobaczyć tę zależność nieco wyraźniej za pomocą rysunku. Jeśli mamy dwa stany i
umieszczamy odległość śladową między nimi na osi x, a wierność na osi y, to odpowiednie linie pionowe
i poziome muszą się przecinać gdzieś w tym szarym obszarze. Najbardziej interesującym obszarem
wykresu, przynajmniej z praktycznego punktu widzenia, jest lewy górny narożnik szarego obszaru. W szczególności gdy
odległość śladowa jest bardzo mała, wierność musi być bardzo bliska jedynki i vice
versa. Te nierówności są używane bardzo często, a częścią powodu jest to, że często bardziej zależy nam na
odległości śladowej ostatecznie, bo ma naturalne interpretację łączącą się z rozróżnianiem stanów kwantowych,
ale wierność ma tyle zadziwiających własności, że jest ogólnie łatwiejsza w użyciu. I o ile jesteśmy w lewym górnym narożniku
szarego obszaru, gdzie często się znajdujemy, nie tracimy zbyt wiele przez przeliczanie między wiernością a odległością śladową. Oto
więc niektóre własności wierności. Jest wiele więcej, ale to dobry początek i mam nadzieję, że ta lista
pomaga zacząć rozwijać intuicję dotyczącą wierności. Oto ładny przykład tego, jak możemy
powiązać wierność z pomiarami nieniszczącymi. To bardzo przydatny fakt znany jako łagodny lemat pomiarowy.
Załóżmy, że mamy układ X, stan X reprezentowany przez macierz gęstości ρ, oraz pomiar układu X
opisany przez kolekcję macierzy dodatnio półokreślonych. Załóżmy, że jeden z wyników pomiaru jest bardzo prawdopodobny,
gdybyśmy wykonali pomiar na stanie ρ. Dla uproszczenia załóżmy,
że to wynik zero jest bardzo prawdopodobny, i w szczególności, że ten wynik pojawia się z
prawdopodobieństwem większym niż 1 − ε dla jakiejś małej wartości ε. Nie musimy faktycznie precyzować ε –
to po prostu jakaś mała dodatnia liczba rzeczywista. Opisaliśmy nasz pomiar tak, jakby był
pomiarem niszczącym, ale wiemy z poprzedniej lekcji, że możemy go zaimplementować w sposób nieniszczący, i konkretnie moglibyśmy to zrobić tak,
jak widzieliśmy w naszej dyskusji o twierdzeniu Neumanna. I działa to tak: każdy wynik a pojawia się z
prawdopodobieństwem równym śladowi P_a × ρ, i po uwarunkowaniu na uzyskaniu tego wyniku stan X zmienia się w
określony sposób. W przypadku uzyskania prawdopodobnego wyniku zero, stan staje się pierwiastkiem z p₀ × ρ × pierwiastka z p₀
znormalizowanym tak, by dać macierz gęstości. I co mówi nam łagodny lemat pomiarowy, to że w tym zdarzeniu,
czyli gdy faktycznie uzyskujemy prawdopodobny wynik pomiaru, otrzymany stan nie zmienił się zbyt wiele od
oryginalnego. W szczególności kwadrat wierności będzie koniecznie większy niż 1 minus
ε. I to jest świetne, bo jest to całkowicie ogólne – nie powiedzieliśmy nic o pomiarze ani
o stanie poza tym, że jeden z wyników jest bardzo prawdopodobny. Zatem lemat może być stosowany w
wielu różnych sytuacjach, gdy chcemy zweryfikować coś o stanie kwantowym bez zbyt dużego jego zakłócania. Zobaczmy więc, jak możemy to
udowodnić, i w większości jest to dość prosta kwestia obliczenia wierności między stanem przed i po pomiarze.
Możemy to zrobić, używając oryginalnej definicji, i zwykle mogłoby to dać nam nieładny wzór, ale
w tym przypadku mamy szczęście, bo to, co jest wewnątrz zewnętrznego pierwiastka, jest w rzeczywistości kwadratem macierzy, która
jest dodatnio półokreślona, co sprawia, że obliczenie pierwiastka jest trywialne. Możemy teraz użyć cyklicznej
własności śladu wraz z liniowością śladu, żeby uprościć nasze wyrażenie, jak pokazano na ekranie. Zauważ nawiasem mówiąc, że są to
same równości, więc nie przybliżaliśmy niczego w tym punkcie – po prostu upraszczamy. Ale teraz potrzebujemy
nierówności, bo chcemy pozbyć się tego pierwiastka w liczniku, i możemy to zrobić, jeśli godzimy się na dolne ograniczenie. Jeśli
interesujesz się szczegółami tej części, możesz dość łatwo uzyskać nierówność, rozważając rozkład spektralny p₀.
Wartości własne p₀ muszą być między 0 a 1 – to zawsze prawda dla macierzy opisujących
pomiary, a gdy to wiemy, nierówność wynika dość bezpośrednio z faktu, że wyciąganie pierwiastka z
liczby między 0 a 1 może ją tylko powiększyć. Inaczej mówiąc, podnoszenie do kwadratu liczby między 0 a
1 może ją tylko zmniejszyć. Możemy teraz trochę uprościć i dostajemy pierwiastek
ze śladu p₀ × ρ. Wreszcie, podnosząc obie strony do kwadratu i
wstawiając nasze ograniczenie na prawdopodobieństwo, dostajemy to, czego chcemy. Zatem wzór na wierność
nie jest najładniejszym ani najłatwiejszym wzorem na świecie, ale tutaj faktycznie działa całkiem
dobrze. Na zakończenie lekcji przyjrzymy się twierdzeniu Uhlmanna, które jest fundamentalnym faktem o wierności,
łączącym ją z pojęciem puryfikacji. Twierdzenie mówi w prostych słowach, że wierność między dowolnymi dwoma
stanami kwantowymi jest równa maksymalnemu iloczynowi wewnętrznemu (wartości bezwzględnej) między dwiema puryfikacjami tych
stanów. Dokładniej, załóżmy, że ρ i σ są macierzami gęstości pewnego układu X, i że Y jest
układem mającym co najmniej tyle klasycznych stanów co X, co gwarantuje nam, że oba stany mają puryfikacje będące
wektorami stanu kwantowego XY. Możemy wtedy wyrazić implikację twierdzenia w formie równania
pokazanego na ekranie: wierność między ρ i σ jest równa maksymalnej wartości bezwzględnej iloczynu wewnętrznego
między F i ψ po wszystkich φ i S puryfikujących odpowiednio ρ i σ.
Uporządkujmy to więc i idźmy dalej z precyzyjnym matematycznym sformułowaniem. To, co teraz zrobimy, to udowodnimy
twierdzenie, ale najpierw warto chwilę docenić, że oferuje nam dość intuicyjny sposób myślenia o
wierności. Jest też dość użyteczne samo w sobie – na przykład do dowodzenia jeszcze ciekawszych rzeczy o
wierności. Żeby je udowodnić, zaczniemy od rozkładów spektralnych naszych macierzy gęstości –
nie ma tu niespodzianek. Gdy mamy rozkłady spektralne, łatwo wymyślić
dwie konkretne puryfikacje tych stanów. Ale tutaj faktycznie wykonamy
pewną sztuczkę. Zauważ, że w obu przypadkach nie mamy wektora standardowej bazy jako drugiego czynnika tensorowego, jak robiliśmy wcześniej w
lekcji, lecz mamy ten sam wektor, co w pierwszym czynniku tensorowym, z tą różnicą, że ma on kreskę nad nim, co
oznacza element po elemencie sprzężoną wersję tych wektorów. Innymi słowy, bierzemy zasadniczo
drugą kopię wektorów własnych, ale bierzemy sprzężoną zespoloną każdego elementu, i zaraz zobaczymy, dlaczego to robimy –
nie jest to wcale oczywiste, i dlatego to nazywamy
sztuczką. W każdym razie są to puryfikacje ρ i σ, i to jest prawdą na mocy
faktu, że nasze wektory własne są ortonormalne, a zatem są nimi też ich element po elemencie sprzężone. Teraz możemy zastosować unitarną
równoważność puryfikacji, która mówi, że każdą puryfikację naszych dwóch stanów można uzyskać przez
zastosowanie operacji unitarnej do układu, który jest wyśledzany. Dla konkretnych wyborów puryfikacji, które
właśnie zrobiliśmy, operacje unitarne nie muszą być takie same dla obu puryfikacji –
oczywiście. Używamy więc litery U dla pierwszej i litery V dla drugiej.
Chodzi więc o to, że każdą puryfikację naszych dwóch stanów można zapisać tak, jak mamy na ekranie, dla pewnych
wyborów operacji unitarnych U i V. Teraz możemy wziąć wyrażenie
z twierdzenia i uprościć. Jeśli wstawimy nasze wyrażenia na F i S i trochę uprościmy,
dostajemy wyrażenie pokazane tutaj na ekranie. Jest tam kilka kroków, których nie pokazałem szczegółów,
więc wiesz co robić, jeśli chcesz to zrobić. Ale wspomnę, że powód, dla którego wybraliśmy puryfikacje w ten sposób,
to umożliwienie, żeby ten iloczyn wewnętrzny uproszczał się dokładnie w ten sposób, i w szczególności wstawiliśmy sprzężenia
zespolone, żeby móc efektywnie odwrócić iloczyny wewnętrzne w drugim czynniku tensorowym, by uzyskać konkretną
formę, którą mamy tutaj. Jesteśmy niemal gotowi – teraz możemy użyć cyklicznej własności śladu wraz
z rozkładami spektralnymi, od których zaczęliśmy, żeby uzyskać to wyrażenie. W tym punkcie możemy
użyć jednego z alternatywnych sposobów wyrażania wierności przy użyciu normy śladowej i
gotowe. Na pewno są tam szczegóły, które przemknąłem bardzo szybko, i jest to rodzaj dowodu, który
naprawdę musisz samodzielnie przepracować, żeby w pełni go pojąć. Ale mam nadzieję, że to daje podstawowe
pojęcie, i jak zwykle więcej szczegółów znajdziesz w pisemnych materiałach do lekcji, podlinkowanych w opisie
filmiku. To koniec lekcji, która była o puryfikacjach, wierności i związkach między nimi. To też
koniec jednostki, która była o ogólnym sformułowaniu informacji kwantowej. Mam nadzieję, że dołączysz do mnie w
czwartej i ostatniej jednostce serii, poświęconej korekcji błędów kwantowych. Dziękuję za oglądanie.